and now with more former speaker of the
house fox news contributor newt gingrich
mr speaker um i
this is what america lasts and
what happens to the world if we have a
weak
american president i want to get your
general thoughts you're more of a
professor and historian than than you
were ever a politician
uh your take on this uh
i i don't even think you can compare joe
to neville chamberlain neville
chamberlain looks strong compared to joe
in my view
no i think that's right i mean
chamberlain was a very
strong political leader who had a
strategy
unfortunately with a personality like
adolf hitler that strategy didn't work
this is it's very bizarre you have
biden yesterday saying yes
putin is a war criminal well what does
that mean
it means nothing
you have biden saying we're going to
really cut them off and make the
sanctions work and then we learn
from
the
free beacon in washington that in fact
the biden administration has already
promised the russians
that if they can get an iranian deal
they will waive the sanctions for at
least 10 billion dollars
of russian construction companies going
into iran
you go through item after item
it struck me and i just wrote a
newsletter on this that you had
zielinski talking about an immediate
urgent now crisis
and you have biden talking about months
and eventually and sooner or later
and you could tell this
when biden spoke two nights ago to the
democratic national committee's
fundraiser and in the entire speech
there's one sentence
about ukraine and russia and that
sentence is that if we had more green
fuels things would be better now when
you can reduce the tragedy that you and
i and everyone watching has seen
in ukraine the viciousness the war
crimes the brutality
and it gets totally ignored by the
president united states
in a speech you know that there's
something
profoundly wrong
with the bible administration and
frankly whatever is wrong with biden is
20 times worse with harris harris's
performance in poland was so humiliating
to every american to have her laughing
when asked about refugees from ukraine i
would say harris should never again be
allowed to leave the united states
because she is such a continuing
embarrassment of to the american people
and she brings the united states in
disrepute nobody in the world thinks
this administration can lead nobody in
the world is going to rely on the
guarantee of
joe biden who has consistently lied lied
about afghanistan has lied about ukraine
it's a it's truly historically a
dangerous moment for the united states
and frankly for the entire human race
they're not even serious i mean maybe
you can make sense of
how why they brought in the tick-tock
influencers into the white house with
with pre-screen questions basically
they're propagandists maybe you can
explain what gensake couldn't explain
and that's the logic behind giving
ukraine drones
and javelins and stinger missiles but
they won't let poland give them the migs
that they have and if you can
extrapolate out the meaning of aoc's
comments um i would i i'd probably give
you the gold star for being a genius
because it makes no sense to me
well in a way you just you just threw
three very different questions at me um
let me start with uh i think the whole i
think the whole thing about mig-29s is
nuts
um if if we're going to put in
anti-aircraft missiles to shoot down so
russian aircraft if we're going to give
them equipment to kill russian tanks
the fact that we allow ukrainian pilots
to fly mig-29s
out of poland or germany or wherever
they come from
strikes me as a non-issue why would you
allow putin
to define what you're allowed to do
which is exactly what joe biden did
and i think that there's no rational
difference in terms of aoc look
her version of climate change is a
religious experience has nothing to do
with reality has nothing to do with
facts and as a religious fanatic in her
own right she can say anything she wants
to because it has to be true because
it's what her religion told her to say
the fact that it's not true factually
makes no sense to normal people uh and
in fact native americans are being
punished like everyone else by having to
pay vastly too much for gasoline and oil
and natural gas because of the policies
of joe biden so in a sense this
administration is punishing native
americans not protecting them and
helping them i think that that's how i
would frame that
let me we could look to the past you're
the historian
we watched ronald reagan he never put a
single american
foot on the ground when the former
soviet union went into afghanistan but
he did provide them stinger missiles and
those stinger missiles to the mujahideen
made all the difference
he did provide the the freedom fighters
the contras in nicaragua the weaponry
that they needed uh that proved
successful then you got the trump
doctrine which took out the caliphate
that grew under biden and obama he just
bombed the living hell out of them
or took out solomonie with the same
principle took out baghdadian associates
no american boots on the ground and took
out the al-qaeda leader in yemen i think
we can learn both from trump but we can
learn from reagan
how to do this and win without risking
american lives your thought
sure well no absolutely the thing that's
frustrating about this administration
whether it's fighting inflation at home
or dealing with crime or dealing with
foreign dangers is we know what works
we've lived through it we lived through
it for eight years with ronald reagan we
lived through it for four years with
donald trump if the price of oil went
back to where it was under trump we
would strip putin of two-thirds of his
daily income we would [ __ ] him
automatically by doing that the very
fact that biden would rather buy buy
gasoline and oil from venezuela which is
a dictatorship
iran which is a dictatorship saudi
arabia is a dictatorship they're okay to
joe biden but now texas oklahoma ohio
pennsylvania north dakota they're really
dangerous places uh you'd have to say
that by any legitimate standard these
people are crazy this is not about
politics this is not about normal
behavior they're nuts
they're out of touch with reality the
world doesn't work the way they think
it's going to and frankly i hope that
the new republican congress in january
will look very deeply at for example how
wrong our intelligence community has
been how wrong millie has been as the
worst chairman of the joint chiefs in
american history remember he was wrong
about afghanistan and then he turned
around and said the russians would be in
kiev in three days he and putin
apparently had the same timetable the
ukrainians didn't know they were
supposed to obey him so the russians
still aren't in kiev now that should
worry all of us because we have 17
intelligence
systems
we spend billions in billions tens of
billions of dollars and they're wrong
now this should lead to really far more
than just joe biden
fundamental reform of the american
system so it works again
all right speaking english always great
to have you thank you sir hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else